very good uh good evening and sorry to
disturb your friday
evening before the beginning of the
weekend
we've just landed actually i don't know
three or four minutes ago
after what has been
a very
important week
i believe
uh for ukraine
and for nuclear safety
uh before i take your your questions um
i want to give you a very quick
overview of how we see the situation at
at the plant and to do that you know i
like to
be graphic and and clear
so that you can have
our best assessment our best technical
assessment of how we see things in a way
which is
clearly
understandable uh for all so as you know
uh we went there with our team
we were all in all 14 and
from the agency including myself and
experts from
the department of safeguards and nuclear
safety and security and i was
accompanied of course by the deputies
and the team that came with me you see
some of them here and six of them
stayed
there
as you know
they were what i conducted there was an
initial um
visit
which lasted you know a few hours we
went on for a few hours i was able to do
many many things there and i'm sure you
will have questions about it so i will
not say everything now at this point
also
after that as you know
six
of our experts remain
uh there they are going to continue
the work that we started
yesterday
and after that um as i also indicated um
in
in kiev and after the the
visit and the inspection in zappos when
i came back and at the plant itself
um
we are establishing our permanent
presence
on site
this time with two of the experts with
which will be continuing the work you
know that i have from the beginning of
this
situation i have been trying to describe
what is going on and its impact on the
safety and the security of the plan
of the plant through a number of pillars
that try to address
the things that
in any
nuclear power plant in any nuclear
installation in the world should be
taken care of
so what i am trying to describe here
with a very simple traffic light type
red yellow or green with all the
agricultures about this this kind of
color based um
description but what is behind here and
sustaining here is a very thorough
technical analysis of course of how we
see the situation uh at the blood so i
will not be spending a lot of time here
just to describe to you how we see it
now so then i can take your direct
questions about that so first is the
physical integrity of the facilities
what you see here is a red it is a big
red why is it a big red is because
they're still we have we have been
seeing um military activity around the
plant and and i was able to see
myself and and my team
impact holes um markings on on buildings
of
shell
so which means that the physical
integrity of the facility has been
violated not once but
several
several times and this is something
irrespective of the
of the kinetic power of whatever you are
throwing at the plant is unacceptable in
any way under any
safety and security creativity
when it comes to the second fear the
second pillar refers to the safety and
security system
being fully functional we assess it with
a yellow because
some of them or most of them are working
and are working
relatively well but there have been
interactions some of them related to the
physical
brake
in in cables or in some
connections uh and still also
in in some systems that are not fully
packed in place so we cannot get the
full information but it's not red it
means that
the activity is continued
sorry
when it comes to i hope that i'm not
yeah you you didn't lose
sorry for that
when it comes to the opera operating
conditions for staff this as you know
has been one of the main points and
continues to be one of the main points
of concern
because this situation in separation we
have this unique unprecedented situation
where you have a ukrainian nuclear power
plant which is
controlled by the russian occupying
forces creating a situation whereby you
have a cohabitation
of
the
operators people the ukrainian
people employees
and professional experts that have been
working there and there are all there is
also presence from
russian
nuclear experts and also military forces
we
we don't put it fully read
for one reason
um yeah and it is that the plant
continues to operate and there is a
professional
um uh
modern defending if you if if i can put
it like that they uh they work together
and the plant as it is obvious because
it has been operating two units
as of today are still operating
including unit number five which was
scrammed
a couple of days ago and now is back in
operation so the all the the physical
conditions are there and the plant
continues to operate the same
code we are applying to off-site power
supply this has also been a matter of
enormous concern and interest
around the world because as you know if
you don't have off-site power supply
the cooling systems for the reactors
cannot work if they can if they cannot
work this can lead to a major accident
we have seen on several locations that
there have been
blackouts or interruptions of one or two
or three of the lines
feeding the plant from
outside at the moment
there is
there are two
operational and what what we know also
is that when there was one situation of
a total complete blackout the diesel
generators operated normally we visited
them i saw them i was talking to those
in charge of that part of the operation
of the plant
logistical aspect and supply chain
this is important in terms of the
replacement you have to think about
zaporizia which is the biggest nuclear
power power plant in europe also as a
big industrial facility as an any
industrial facility you need spare parts
there are things that need to be
replaced and so on and so forth given
the anomalous situation of a war it is
obvious that logistical chains are
interrupted we were quite probing about
it about this we were discussing with
people on site and the impression that
they gave us is that
here there are no major problems there
are some interruptions hence the
qualification we are putting here and in
the case of the radiation monitoring and
emergency
response we have
we have had some complete interruptions
hence the half red situation but also
some systems are working well so
we we do see
a mix a mixed bar in terms of reliable
communications with a regulator it is
also an operating
function with some uh difficulties so
this gives you a birth eye view
of the of a situation which we are of
course uh not wanting to analyze in any
way we believe and i continue to believe
that the situation is extremely complex
extremely
challenging and it will continue to
require the permanent
the permanent support and the monitoring
that we are trying to provide now that
we are there so now that i gave you this
general overview i am open
to your questions thank you very much
a couple questions first of all what do
you know now that you didn't know just
before going to
separation
and secondly you mentioned
specifically on the iaea presence
you mentioned six people who are there
now i think if i heard
who will stay on are they supposed to
stay there till the end of the war or
are they going to get rotated out so
what's the plan
well
i start with the easiest part so the the
those who are there will continue to be
there
the end of the war we all wish for that
we hope it happens soon we don't know
we believe that it was important
it was important for the agency to be
there permanently
and
and this is a good segue for you first
the first part of the question you were
saying what do you know now that you
didn't know before
we knew a lot
but of course
our
trade is inspected
the difference between being there and
not being there is like day and night
so excuse me so
many things we had information
including remote data
transmission etc but when it comes to
many other things that are important
it's very different to go now i saw
and
as sdg but also my technical experts
things that were being said
and we were able to assess the
seriousness of them and what other
questions
you can compare it with the inspections
in the safe criteria you you see
something then you ask something else so
we know much more and we are learning
even more as we speak okay
i guess what i was getting at is the
fact that you said you're going to
report to the board of governors
and so i'm trying to get a sense of you
know how much information you expect to
happen by then
at what point you obtain this
information
well we are getting this information
all the time
well we have been getting it from the
very beginning and now we are trying to
have an in-depth assessment of how
things
stand at the moment i expect to produce
a report
early
next week
as soon as we have the full picture of
the situation
by the end of the weekend more or less
hi youtube how are you doing i hope
you're fine we are we are fine i'm happy
to be back home okay so
my main question to you what is it that
you are
what is your biggest concern in terms of
the safety of the plant i mean we can
see the red
spot here on the physical integrity
what is it that could happen what is it
that
you are mostly worried about
we all know about who is necessarily the
radioactive waste storage that is there
what is it that you are mostly concerned
about and i also have another question
you mentioned that there is a cool
habitation between the ukrainian staff
and the russian occupiers could you give
us a bit of a sense of the atmosphere of
what is it like
well
yeah it's yours is a very deep question
stephanie it's a very deep question that
has
human and psychological factors
that
i i would i should be very prudent in in
answering what i can tell you is that
the the the plant is operating there is
a professional
relationship
between these experts they are all
nuclear experts so they know what they
are doing they know what they are
talking about
but they are human beings
and they have sides
on a wall that is affecting them and
their families
so
the situation is
one of
i would say it's admirable uh for the
ukrainian experts to continue to work in
in this conditions in the way they they
are doing they care for the facility
they they work very very well but of
course there is a there is a tension
there is a latent
tension there because uh of the obvious
reasons uh of of of the war
so
i would say
this is something that needs to be must
be
dealt with enormous
caution
and again our presence there is uh
has a very big
added value
i believe because we can interact with
people
constantly
frequently throughout days they know
that the iaea people are there so i
think it is very important that we have
this
this presence there i missed something
of your question
that was the second question my first
question was
what is the most
well
well you know uh
i i think we we have to be uh looking at
the the the main points and when it
comes to the main points first of all is
the physical integrity why
and here i don't i will i will not get
into that but i will simply mention that
it is obvious
that there is a lot of
uh fighting
in the region in general in this part of
ukraine
so
the
military activity and operations are
increasing
in that part
of the country
and this worries me a lot
this worries me a lot
there are references to offensives
counter offensives i don't want to get
into that because it's not my domain but
it is obvious and we all know it and
everybody acknowledges it
on
on-site
so it is obvious that the
statistical
possibility of more physical damage
is
is present
let me give you an example
the
physical damage
to the plant
with the exception of the event on the
night of the 3rd to the 4th of march
with this fire
the shelling
actually started in august
so it is quite clearly a more a more
recent
trend if i can call it like that so what
we see with this increase of military
activity
is that the physical
integrity is more
compromised and with that
we i i take you to full i take you to
the
to the power supply because it is clear
that those who have
these aims these military aims
know very well that uh the way to
[ __ ] or to or to do more damage is
not to look into the reactors which are
enormously sturdy and robust but to
you know hit
where it hurts so the plant becomes
you know very very problematic so
my
my concern would be
you know the physical integrity would be
the power supply and of course the staff
so these are the areas the rest are
things that we can work on radiation
systems
supply chain all very very important all
very important but of course they have a
lesser degree if you want dramatism when
it comes to what if i have to address
your question directly thank you next
time
and
how true are you that the agreement that
those signs will be
how sure i am uh i
you know uh i can we can never be sure
what we need to do is to always try
and to improve if you look at what we
have now
it is far far better that we used to
have now i have my people i was there
we have a big team there we have people
who are going to stay there this has
tremendous
value
this is a huge difference and of course
if something happens or is if if any
limitation or
comes
they are going to be reporting it
they're reporting it to us it is no
longer a matter of
a said this and b
said the contrary
now the iaea is there
and this
is
like i said
from night to day
in terms of the people being there
naturally for me the safety of my people
is the first thing
you remember that i said i will never
send somebody to a place where i don't
go myself first
and this is what i have been doing now
that we know that we have a certain
degree as a system
that is
working
we have our people there
and it has been very challenging of
course we are
we are looking at this they are in
constant communication with us if
something happens of course we will take
the necessary measures thank you
jordy hello jordan
so just to be clear the two who stay are
in the group of the six who are there
now yes and the four are coming back
next week something at some point and
with whom did you negotiate
both sides agreed that these two people
would stay there yes
yes yes and
the four will come back the way you came
back which is going to be a different
way well there are logistic aspects
related to that but they are going to
continue to count and thank you for the
question because i want to recognize the
support
that we received from the united nations
department of safety and security we
have incredibly good people there that
are coming from the most you know
difficult
hot spots in the world and that they
were accompanying us and guiding us
through what they themselves recognized
was a very challenging
thing so they are going of course to
continue to have the support but does
that mean for example that's this
regular updates were standing which said
the ukrainian side told us this and this
it will change now it will be over your
own information of course
yes
there are informations that you uh don't
have the access to the inner circle of
the facility
can you confirm this
what do you mean sorry by the inner
circle
let me explain
the
every nuclear power plant has
has a
crisis center a center where
certain operations can be handled in
every circumstance this place is being
used for other
things but there has been a another
center set up
for the facility to continue working so
there is no uh i would say influence in
the operation of the plant because of
the non-availability of this place that
has been chosen of course by the
military occupiers to have a place
i cannot get into that because i don't
know frankly i'm not hiding anything
from you but um but it is it is it is
obvious and we will be recommending that
that the plant should have its normal um
you know operational centers and rooms
for that i want to emphasize this
because
this
idea i have seen in some of the comments
and reactions that we were not shown
that we were
paraded we've seen what i requested to
see
everything i requested to see even as we
were going along
when something we thought should be seen
i said i want to go here and there and
we saw everything
i want to emphasize
this because i think it's very important
when we go somewhere we do what we need
to do and if we are prevented from doing
it we just come back and say
we were not able
to do it so thank you for the question
welcome back to and for everybody from
the group
you mentioned that
yes thank you yeah
you mentioned that the presence of the
iaea is very
necessary to stabilize the situation now
apart from getting the hands-on
information from the group who are going
to be there
whatever what else do you expect
this presence would help you know what
is your expectation of having them there
in terms of studying well
that's not a question
could i
you know there are expertise of three
major areas security safety and
safeguards and now you're
leaving two people are they the safety
people or are they the safeguards
because safeguards was one of the top
agenda actually although it wasn't
really just reported too much but yes
thank you for thank you for you so what
what would be the constellation and
um would that
hinder your presence in assessing
if one of the three is missing among the
two
well what we try when we put together
our teams with the support of my
deputies here we try to have the best
combination of knowledge
as necessary for what we believe
we are going to be doing at the plant
we
we chose a very
experienced
team
and i can assure you that we will at all
times have the necessary knowledge on
site on safety and security and on
safeguards it could be two could be
three but um
at all times we are going to be able to
to have that and so and the first
question was yeah what's that how is
that going to help to stabilize the
situation well uh this is this question
of yours of course has a subjective
factor to it um but i would say that um
the fact that the iaea is there that we
have our people there informing 24 hours
a day
assessing what is going on and for those
who may have
intentions on the plant knowing that
international inspectors are there
witnessing and informing immediately
what is happening has um i think an
inherent
very important
stabilizing effect i don't want to
aggrandize or pretend that what we are
doing is going to either
settle this
terrible war
or
give back the plant to ukraine this is
beyond our capacities
what we are doing there is stabilizing
looking at the safety the security of
the safeguards aspects of the plant
in the conviction
that if we get this right
this will have
some very
influence in what happens overall
ukraine criticizes that the iaea does
not speak up clearly in favor of
demilitarizing the zone around the
nuclear power plant by russia on the
other side welcomes your presence there
by also protecting the site militarily
and doesn't that make the ira a
political play
listen your question
which is
a very interesting one can apply to
everything we do
if you look at other situations with
other countries that i'm not going to
mention now because they are not part of
the discussion today
you will find the same thing
when people
tend to like what we say
they will
praise us
when they don't like it they will say
that the disease is a puppet of whomever
or that we are being manipulated or that
we are we are never manipulated we we
never lose our law we know what we what
we need to do and we we listen of course
respectfully to all this noise
but our ability is to you know keep
focus on on what we need to do
we
are aware of the comments and of course
it is very legitimate
for member states to expect
that the agency or myself will say
exactly what they would like me what i
would like
the dg to say
of course
i have to be
very clear in what i do i have to be
prudent in what i say my responsibility
is a
360 degree
one so i have to be looking at all the
factors involved and how everything i
say will be affecting other important
pieces of the operation that we are
having so
frankly speaking there are enough
political players in this game
and there are enough people saying what
they feel or condemning one or the other
the nuclear watchdog has to remain what
it is
the nuclear
security safety and non-proliferation
watchdog and it has to do its job to
have its credibility
we respect and we understand that people
have these expectations that we will
demand uh these things but what we
believe is that where the iea adds value
is in its technical work not if i am one
more of those saying a or b against a
or b
and since we can ask two questions yes
you're right um do you think the iaea
can now stay constantly there to
watch the site and
give us information you know i hope we
are not going to be constantly there i
hope that
normalcy
will return
i hope that there will be a day not in
the you know any distant future
where the plant is going to be operating
again normally
with it with its normal owners and
operators and we are going to be
visiting periodically as as we did
i think in all its drama
and in all its tragedy
this proves why you need
organizations like the iaea that can go
there try to provide a degree of
stability a degree of certainty about
what is going on now when you will hear
that there is an allegation that
something has happened at the plant
you will be able to turn to us because
you are doing it now but now we have
people there people who are going to be
telling this is the situation this is
what happened we are talking to a b and
c or the engineers or and this is what
we see or
we are not being allowed
we are locked in a room disease
what's going on and then we will know we
are in trouble so i think that's the
difference
my question is and you said you're
technical experts but for sure you
met the
heavy armed soldiers you spoke of them
how was the connection with them was it
terrifying with them were they friendly
and did you maybe try to speak about the
diminutionarized area with them or was
it clear no no speaking of this can you
tell us about the atmosphere with the
russian soldiers
i would say that the military
present
those there did not approach us in any
way
were not available for i asked for a
couple of occasions to um to talk to
one of them but they were not available
precisely on this issue of the of the of
the control center of the crisis center
because i wanted to ask
why they were there and if this
room could be returned
to its normal functions but
it was evident that this group was very
withdrawn
uh throughout
our our presence there but what we got
from our ukrainian
counterparts is that in general this is
the case they are working with their
russian technical counterparts
and i described the situation before
it's not an easy situation it's a tense
situation it's not an ideal situation
it's a situation everybody is coping
with
questions
[Music]
it is possible it is happening it has
been happening since the plant was
occupied
there is a military force
that has taken over not only the plant
that part of your brain
and they are in control
the plant continues some decided to
leave the plant and are not working
there anymore some decided to to be
there and to continue
in in their work
this is why
i have been saying that this is a
situation that it is not
we cannot envisage this to continue for
a very long time until there is clarity
about what is going to happen these
people basically are very fundamentally
uncertain about the future as we all are
do you know what's going to happen with
the war i i don't you don't we hope for
peace but we don't have it yet
and second question very short
especially in austria for example
well the i would say
i've heard comparisons and they they
make sense in terms of the public
interest because people of course relate
to chernobyl i think the situations are
quite incomparable
uh
these these are operating nuclear power
plants they have degrees of safety that
are immensely higher than
what happened there
there are however
risks in terms for example of the
spent fuel storage
which which is there in case it was
attacked or there was an impact there it
would of course not be comparable to
what happened at that time but it could
have transboundary perhaps effects
original it would depend you know i i
don't like to
avoid the question but i don't like to
speculate too much because you know it
could be
you know a big thing or a small thing
depending on on the
damages yes did anything surprise you
a lot of things to describe the things
that you know pretty much what we'd
expect or what we've done before were
you surprised
not surprised
not surprised
okay no more questions
[Music]
permanent
so hearing from you i got the impression
that you will be there as long as the
military forces are present
so that the red dot in number one
will not go away unless they move away
so here i understand that iaea intends
to stay until the military forces
i said yesterday you are right the iaea
is there to stay for as long as it me as
it is needed yes we are not leaving we
are not going anywhere
yes but my question was that is that
means that until the military forces
move away
either by force or peacefully either way
well we would evaluate at that time we
had a similar situation with chernobyl
you remember
chernobyl was occupied as well and on
the 31st of march
there was an evacuation
interestingly
that
didn't mean
that the iaea left
it meant that we came even
in bigger numbers with more help to
assist them to reconstruct the safety
structures and we have a big program of
assistance which by the way we are also
planning to have
four zaparica
when
when we as soon as we can
of course as soon as we as i said we
have to be realistic we are dealing with
realities let me thank you all
for for your interest
we are going as i said to continue
our work
at the plant there
and hopefully have a
deeper degree of information
hoping that
this is going to help stabilize
the whole thing on tuesday i am going to
be briefing the united nations security
council about our findings and what
happened i thank you again and i wish
you a nice weekend to you thank you very
much for having me
[Music]